madame alice saunier
séité vous la voyez d'ailleurs moi aussi
d'ailleurs
le secrétaire d'état aux universités
louvois mais tient le cap
l'arrêté réformant les études
supérieures du second cycle ne sera pas
annulée là dessus du premier ministre
secrétaire d'état ça paraît clair mais
pour qu'un arrêté soit applicable
il faut des textes d'application et là
on peut jouer c'est ce qu'en substance
madame sonia cité a dit ce matin aux
représentants de la fédération de
l'éducation nationale ce qui a pu être
considérée comme une concession
d'où un certain flottement dans le
mouvement contestataire à vrai dire et
vous allez en être témoin madame sony
slt n'a rien dit de plus semble-t-il ce
matin aux représentants syndicaux
rien de plus par rapport à ce qu'elle
avait déclaré hier soir au cours de
notre émission spéciale sur les
universités est venu l'arrêter
oui bon c'est un cadre tellement large
que il n'ya vraiment pas à revenir
dessus
je pense que si nous voulons mettre en
place de nouvelles formations en octobre
1970 secte
nous pouvons plus nous mettre à discuter
pendant des semaines sur l'arrêté qui
est un cadre très large et qui permet
beaucoup de choses
je crois qu'il est temps que nous nous
mettions à discuter et à nous concerter
sur sa mise en application bien dans sa
campagne de charme et d'explication de
sa réforme à l'âme saunier séité fait
preuve d'un peu de souplesse et de
beaucoup de diplomatie
elle ne modifie rien mais le ton et les
termes employés on change et puis il
n'est plus question de faire les gros
yeux pour les diplômes les examens
seront passe voilà qui s'adresse en
premier lieu aux étudiants modérer les
silencieux les in organisé dans l'espoir
de leur faire reprendre le chemin de
l'université
la campagne vise aussi le collectif
d'amiens en espérant là que les groupes
les moins virulents changeront eux aussi
de ton sait-on jamais auprès des
étudiants les plus engagés madame
saunier séité n'a aucune chance de
convaincre la grève va se poursuivre et
même se durcir dans certains endroits au
moins jusqu'à la manifestation nationale
de jeudi
après on verra mais le secrétaire d'état
joue aussi sur un autre tableau
l'opinion publique
inquiète bien sûr par l'agitation mais
qui visiblement ne comprend pas les
problèmes des étudiants ils ont toujours
eu ses étudiants une mauvaise image de
marque
depuis le commencement madame sonia
séité est seul face aux contestataires
le monde politique et le monde syndical
ne se sont guère fait entendre en fait
le public ne s'y retrouvent plus guère
d'autant que maintenant on voit
apparaître dans la rue des comités anti
grève comme ce matin à paris j'avais
deux positions et la position des
grévistes qui refuse toute concertation
et au dialogue avec le secrétariat
d'état aux universités et qui prône
l'abrogation totale de la réforme ça ce
sont les mouvements comme l'une est
comme les extrémistes de gauche et qui
bloque carrément la situation est là
l'autre côté vous avez des gens qui
prônent la reprise des cours et qui à
travers cette reprise des cours ne
veulent pas laisser la réforme telle
qu'elle est mais veulent en discuter
avec le secrétariat d'état aux
universités veulent accepter ce dialogue
et cette concertation est ce qu'il y a
véritablement cette peur de ne pas avoir
des diplômes
donc c'est du côté des galeries je crois
que le blocage psychologique est fait et
que de toute façon ils iront jusqu'au
bout
quant aux non grévistes je compte la
réflexion qu'il voudrait entamer est
beaucoup plus sérieuse et se préoccupe
effectivement leur répugne à travers
leurs édiles se préoccupe effectivement
de ce qui sera leur futur c'est à dire
de cette réforme
donc dans un premier temps il ya
peut-être ce problème des diplômes de la
validation de la universitaire mais je
crois aussi que c'est important c'est de
discuter de la réforme est donc de
préparer l'avenir
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
vous n'êtes pas très nombreux en dix ans
nous avons un problème nous n'avons pas
les moyens qu'ont d'autres nous n'avons
pas ces moyens d'information au point
d'autres hélas nous ne sommes qu'au
début du mouvement anti vrai mais nous
pensons l'élargir et prendre contact
avec les comités anti brown le pari de
la france selon vous est ce que vous
pensez qu'une reprise des cours est
précipitée semaine les jours qui
viennent je croyais quand je crois
qu'effectivement une reprise des cours
est possible à condition à condition que
nous ayons les moyens d'action et
d'information qui nous permet de
mobiliser les gens qui veulent reprendre
les cours